thank you quite an introduction quite a
class wow that's great governor welcome
to the GSB thank you
welcome to the view from the top we're
excited to have you here because you've
managed to be at the top of I think at
last count at least four organizations
and so we want to talk about your
professional success and management
skills but one thing the Dean mentioned
which i think is particularly important
is your commitment to personal success
your family your community your faith
and I want to start by an anecdote which
is actually the first time we met and I
haven't told you the story though you
know I grew up in your hometown for some
time and that's twenty-one years ago you
invited a bunch of Boy Scouts over to
your house when I was nine years old to
have a oh yeah no it's good
we're still cleaning up that mess yeah
yeah so you invited a bunch of us over
your house I think there's about 30 boys
and we were there on a Saturday or
Sunday and you spent the day with us all
day grilling burgers it was a pool party
and I'm struck by two things as I
remember that story one is that there
aren't very many parties I remember from
being nine years old so you clearly know
how to throw a very good party serving
beer to kids as always yeah right so
thank you for that the second is that
you know on reflecting on this story I
realized that this was roughly around
the time you were running Bain Capital
and about to embark on a Senate campaign
and that really struck me there the
press is filled with stories when you
were leading major organizations but
still found time for these kind of
examples and the word having it all gets
thrown around a lot but you have sort of
managed to have it all you have a great
career you have a great family you're
committed your community I want to know
how you've managed to strike that
balance and have it all I don't know
that I've spent a lot of time analyzing
how you balance your life at one point I
remember feeling that I wasn't doing as
much as I should be doing in my home
with my kids also feeling I wasn't doing
as much as I should be doing at work and
also feeling I wasn't doing as much as I
should at church in my assignment there
and then realizing that meant things
were pretty well in ballots and and
there maybe it's humorous perhaps but
there's some truth of that which is if
you're spending all your time in one
aspect of your life and not devoting it
to other things that are important to
you then obviously things are out of
whack a couple of things I backed into
you're in the joint program business law
program I I came from Brigham Young
University to Harvard and was convinced
I would flunk out and because I looked
around I saw these people who were
obviously smarter than me and and how
was I possibly going to make it in this
environment except by just studying like
crazy and so I studied all the time and
if I was not studying I felt like
there's this black cloud hanging over me
I should be studying
got to be working because I'm gonna
flunk out and and it was omnipresent at
at some point I finally said you know
what I'm gonna do something which which
goes back to biblical times I'm gonna
take sunday off I'm gonna decide I'm not
going to study at all on Sunday and I'm
gonna devote that day to my family to
worship and just personal time and it
was amazing what happened when I made
that decision because then on that
Sunday I didn't feel the black cloud
there anymore it's like okay I I can't
study today I don't have to worry about
it and and the same thing happened as I
went into my career in the consulting
industry I said you know what I'm just
not going to work when I come home at
the end of the day it may be a late
night and maybe I get home at 6:00 or
7:00 instead but when I come home I'm
going to close my brief briefcase and
that work and I'm going to devote the
time I have at home to my family and it
was wonderful it was just it was it was
freeing because I could really focus on
the things that I cared most about in
life which which were my wife and my
kids and now of course if there was a
big presentation coming up why I you
know I break that rule but in terms of a
regular pattern of life those were a
couple things I did Sunday stayed for me
a day of family coming home at the end
of the day stayed a family time I
traveled a good deal of course was I I
was on the road I worked like crazy late
into the night but a few of those
decisions early on shaped how I spent my
time and probably helped me balance my
life to towards those things that
mattered most to me so how did you get
away with that I mean there's a lot of
people I mean all of us come from these
you know careers or going into these
careers where if you say I'm gonna go
home at 6 o'clock I'm sorry that you
know that's not always met with a lot of
positive that's ya know I may have
misspoke and there some nights I might
have been able to get home at 7 take
Sunday and but but I
but I found if you take a block of time
off for yourself you may well be more
productive than if you don't
and and that may not be true depending
on the organization you go to but I'm
when I was talking to Bill Bain about
joining Bain & Company I said look I
have to take all day Sunday off so if
there's like a company meeting or if you
want to come in for case team meetings
on Sunday I just won't be there and if
that's something that that the firm
can't accept that I'm probably not the
right guy for the firm and and I live by
that again unless it was some kind of a
an unusual experience some you know
terrible crisis happened I was going to
jump in with both feet like everybody
else but that was the everyday
occurrence and I think it made me more
effective and more productive and I had
good consulting assignments and got
promoted as time went on so I don't
think it hurts to have something more in
your life than just work I think I think
having faith or a community that you
care about politics and children I think
that makes you a more full human being
more able to understand how the world
works and how most people think and may
actually make you more effective and by
the way if it doesn't and you don't get
promoted in the way you wanted to and
you don't make as much money as you
wanted to
so what life is not about getting
promoted in money if that's how you
measure your life I got some bad news
there's serendipity in the world bad
things happen in business in the economy
you can't be guaranteed you're going to
get promoted and make a lot of money but
if you measure yourself by the things
that count most to you your relationship
with your spouse your friendships your
children your family those things you
can succeed at whether or not the world
goes to hell in a handbasket so you know
I think you lay out how you want to live
your life and and and you do that you
can have success regardless of what
happens in the world around you you
mentioned your time at Harvard and how
this kind of came to you then this this
need to create some sectors in your life
one of the other decisions you made at
Harvard was your graduating with a
jd/mba you decided to go into management
consulting I'm curious for all of us
making these kind of choices today if
you have similar interests and we're
here where we are today would you make
the same decision to go to management
consulting and I ask that as a jd/mba
yeah you're going into management
consultants are a
I hope the answer is yeah canola yeah no
I mean my path was very different than
the success books suggested I mean there
are books out there that said you know
you ought to have a clear goal in mind
and think about that goal and I grew up
in Detroit
my dad was a car company CEO and I fully
anticipated to go work for an automobile
company that's what I wanted to do and
so after my first year in the JD MPA
program I went to work at Chrysler
Corporation and thinking that's where I
was going to go and I hated it I was so
deep in the organization and of course
the people I mean my boss's boss's boss
had never met the CEO and never would
and and decisions being made that would
affect the success of that company I'd
never have any impact on unless I was
there 50 or some odd years and I thought
boy this is just not at all like I
imagined it and and so I came back in
the second year and got a job I think
was my second you're in the program I
got a job with the Boston Consulting
Group for a summer job and it was
fascinating and it was exciting and I
loved it and and so I it was not a great
analysis I did to say this is the right
next step for my career I just enjoyed
it I mean I am my path in life has
primarily been focused on doing things I
thought were fun and enjoyable and so
that was fun I mean my my undergraduate
major was English I was it why would you
go into English what I mean there's no
future right as an English major what
are you gonna do alright and and but I
like reading and I liked writing so when
I took English is my major and then
coming out of business school in law
school I wanted a consulting because I
enjoyed it
not because that's where I thought I'd
spend my life I expected that I'd be
there for two or three years like most
people do and then get a job in a in a
line corporation of some kind and and
and perhaps move up more aggressively by
having started in consulting I loved
consulting because I am I oriented
toward solving problems I like analysis
and data and problem solving and writing
and writing presentations that's what I
like to do that's what took me there
and so I would I would go to those I
followed the career paths that you enjoy
most as opposed to trying to follow a
career path that you think will will
lead to the highest income or the the
quick quickest promotion do what you
enjoy and and then your life will be
enjoyable and fulfilling so one other
thing you you you are known for is
parachuting into very troubled
environments you went from being capped
act to being consulting to turn that
around
he went from bein cap to the Olympics
turned that around and then you
parachuted into my home state of
Massachusetts and helped turn that
around as well what what led you to make
those decisions what were you looking at
to make those kind of like pretty risky
bets yeah I don't know that I have
jumped into troubled situations because
I enjoy troubled situations i but it is
a sense of obligation and and maybe it's
my upbringing or my faith or I say
upbringing my parents my dad had this
sense of obligation to the country and
my dad was born in Mexico of American
parents living there there was a
revolution at the time came back to
United States lived in public housing
got public assistance and and grew up
poor very poor and had a perhaps as a
result of that upbringing in the
opportunity in his life that that
developed over time had a great sense of
obligation to America and to the
community and so whenever he felt that
there was a need that wasn't being met
he volunteered and jumped in and and
somehow I felt the same way so in the
first step you mentioned going from Bain
Capital which was highly successful and
and growing like crazy and Bain
consulting was in trouble and it was in
trouble because of financial steps that
have been taken by the founders and it
looked like it might disappear
altogether and I was asked by the
partners of the consulting firm if I
would leave Bain Capital for a couple of
years and come back and run the
consulting firm and I felt like how
could I say no there were a thousand
people who were working at
main consulting at that point and I
figured that there was a very high risk
it wouldn't make it
I had the particular skills that were
most needed at that point financial
skills because they needed a financial
reengineering as well as some leadership
skills and so I came back to the
consulting firm the Olympics why go to
the Olympics I mean I I pointed this out
before there was some irony that a
person of such limited athletic talent
would be running running the I mean I
didn't even let her in a sport in high
school but I'd be I'd be running the
premier sporting event in the world but
I I and I was not a big fan of the
Olympics when I heard that Utah won the
games just like yeah you know so what
who cares weather and and but then when
I got asked to take a close look at it
when it was in trouble a few things
weighed in my mind
one was that this was the community my
parents have been raised in and and it
was going to be tarnished by a potential
scandal number two I began to recognize
that the Olympics is one of the few
remaining places in the world where
where young people get to see day in and
day out the great qualities of the human
spirit from hard work and dedication to
patriotism the teamwork passion to to
determination I mean the list goes on
and on we watch the Olympics not because
we're enthralled with bobsled you know
or ski jumping but instead because we
see these young people from around the
world in a crucible of stress rising
above it all and great things are our
view and so I thought it's important
these games go on and I have the
particular skill set that's probably
needed at a time like this to get the
games back on track so came and the same
thing running for governor my we had a
Republican governor at the time I was
considering coming back after the
Olympics and running for governor but
the approval rating of a Republican
governor was 13% and and a number of
Republican leaders said we really would
really appreciate you coming back in and
applying what you've learned and your
prior experiences to help our state turn
around we've got this massive
massive deficit and a lot of people
could lose jobs we're going to lose our
economic edge as a state can you come
back and that's what that's what drew me
and that's by the way why end up running
for president it was out of a sense of
obligation and and love for the country
and a sense that I was in the right
place at the right time and with one
thing you've heard the quote many times
but my mother asked it or said it all
the time if not now when if not here
where and if not me who and and she said
if you're the right person at the right
time how can you possibly walk away I'm
interested because clearly your drive
comes from this commitment to public
service but you mentioned your father as
a great influence on you and you talk
about him a lot and one of the quotes
from your documentary on you is you
talking about him and saying you know
you always think about dad and how you
stand on his shoulders how could you go
from his beginnings to I can run for
president I started off where he ended
up and that that's a very
self-reflective statement that I think
is really interesting and I'm wondering
how much of his success pushes you to
strive higher to aim higher to push
yourself more than maybe you would have
otherwise you know I think some people
compete with their dad or their mom
because they have a sense that that that
will fulfill who they are or will define
them as a success because they beat
their dad or they beat their mom I'm not
in that category I didn't feel in any
way I needed to compete with my dad in
part because he wasn't competitive with
with family or friends or whatever he a
guy entirely without guile that said
what my dad and my mom taught us in our
home and the way they lived their life
affected the way I developed and and led
me to have certain skills I probably
wouldn't have had without that
upbringing and gave me a perspective on
life I probably wouldn't have had
without being raised in their home I was
young luck lucky to be the youngest in
the family and and I was six years
younger than my next oldest sibling and
the result of that was that I was kind
of home with my parents for the last six
years after my brother went off to
school and so dad could take me to work
with him and and I would watch my
had first when I was younger at American
Motors interacting with executives there
then I saw him as governor and would go
to meetings and watch him my summer jobs
are working in the governor's office
signing his name by the way on a notary
certificates alright it's very strange
that I authorized people's signatures
with my dad's call signature but
nonetheless I got I got to watch I got
to watch how my dad interacted with
people not recognizing that I was really
learning from that experience and so
yeah my dad and and and to a great
extent also my mom and the commitment
they made to family and church and
community shaped what I felt was right
about how I should live my life I want
to turn to leadership and management and
talk about some of the success stories
you've had of which there are many I'm
curious when you go you've led multiple
different types of organizations private
sector public sector nonprofit when you
go into any of these situations are
there any leadership or management
principles you take with you no matter
where you go that you found successful
you know and I mentioned this to you
Ryan before we came in here and that is
I was one day sitting with a the chief
financial officer of my state who was
someone I had hired from Bain Capital
and before that he'd worked at Bain and
I had been consulting so I knew him well
Eric chris is his name and a nephew of
Milton Friedman by the way but Eric said
to me mitt there are two types of
leaders one is the kind of leader that
knows the particular techniques and
skills they use in leading and the other
is someone who has no clue why they're a
leader you're in the latter group so I'm
not sure I'm going to be able to help
you with this with this question but
there are there's no question in my mind
but the things that that allowed me to
be effective in consulting and then in
helping form a private equity firm and
venture capital firm and then in the
Olympics and then in the state that
those kinds of attributes passed from
one one sphere to the next I don't know
what they all are one is I believe
having a clear vision of where you want
to go and and being able to articulate
that to yourself perhaps writing it down
I tend to I take
the notes section of my iPad and and
we'll we'll write down what it is I want
to accomplish and think about precisely
what I hope to accomplish with a
particular assignment so I'll write that
down so having a clear objective I think
is important number two I think it's
important to know what your values are I
didn't ever write that down I just knew
what they were but for me people and and
associations with other people and
friendships with people were more
important than than any other aspect of
what an enterprise might be doing more
important than profit more important
than gaining market share more important
than promotion what were the feelings I
had for other people and they had for me
and so I have I don't try and treat
people with respect I do treat people
with respect because I respect people
it's not that I say to myself to be an
effective leader I have to be respectful
of people know I mean I'm respectful of
people because I respect other human
beings as being sons and daughters of
God and and equal in all respects to me
so that that is I think that's as part
of kind of me again I get that from my
parents that's as part of who you are or
who you aren't as the case may be I
don't think you can fake that and and I
mentioned one other thing and then you
can you can come back to it I like or
push me further if you like as a
management style I like extensive
participation I like a lot of
give-and-take I remember on one occasion
the chief of staff while I was serving
as governor came in and she said look we
had this tough decision to make about
whether to spend I camera how many
hundreds of millions of dollars putting
in this new subway line and and and she
said I'm going to bring in the cabinet
members we all agree that we should do
it all of us have met we've gone through
the numbers and and the pros and cons
and we all agree we should do it they
all sat there and I said does anyone
here disagree with this decision and
they said no we're all on board and I
said that I can't possibly go ahead
what do you mean I said well I have to
have someone here who disagrees we've
got to have someone who can make an
argument for why it's a bad decision
please go back and find if you have to
someone on the other side of the aisle
in the center to the house or
who really disagrees with this and then
let's take it apart once we can have
that kind of debate I love that kind of
exchange and debate and and not because
you know I think I'm the judge you can
always pick out the the right answer but
because I enjoy the give-and-take and
the metal exchange and I find when you
have that kind of exchange often times I
end up being wrong
often times others are wrong but we
learn from it and I'm entirely
non-defensive about whether my answer
the what the preconceived notion I came
in with was right or not I only care
about getting the right answer and if
the as a group we can come up with the
right answer I don't care whose idea it
was
it's like yeah let's let you know it's
the fun and the engagement of drawing on
people and their experience that I that
I find compelling and I'll mention one
more thing and that is I used to think I
should spend my time as a leader working
with people to help them overcome their
weaknesses and then I realized that's a
waste of time because by and large
people don't overcome their weaknesses
instead I found that my job was to help
people take advantage of their strengths
and if they had weaknesses to find ways
to to accommodate that by bringing in
other people who had the strengths where
they had weaknesses or where I had
weaknesses and I do by the way and by
the way I've tended to bring in people
who who can complement my own weaknesses
and and so at Bain Capital for instance
I we're a very different group of people
it's not that the this the eighteen
partners that were there when I left now
there are over a hundred but the
eighteen partners who were there had
very different personalities and skills
in part because I saw my job is not
trying to make them all the same but
instead taking advantage of the
particular skills people had and
encouraging those things and filling in
the blank spots or the flat spots where
they may not have been may not have been
quite as effective your most recent
management challenge was your
presidential organization and I'm
curious I didn't win yes I did hear that
and
and and that's what I actually want to
ask about is when you look back at
managing that organization I know
everyone can play Monday Morning
Quarterback in politics but when you
look back at managing that organization
what was different about managing a
presidential campaign and and maybe what
would you have done differently if you
looked at it from a management
standpoint again
well a candidate is by and large not the
manager of the campaign and and and that
has brought home to you day in and day
out by the people who are managing the
campaign and and and so I you know I I
have run for office before I worked on
my mother's campaign for US Senate I
worked on my father's campaigns my
father ran for governor three times it
was elected three times he ran for
president was not elected but I worked
on my dad's campaigns my mother's
campaign and the candidate is really out
there speaking the candidate is out is
out doing that the job of connecting
with people and and and and taking the
message to the to the voting public the
people running the campaign you choose
like you would if you were the the
chairman of the board and you choose
someone to be the chief executive
officer or the chief operating officer
and you have both in the campaign you
have a CEO and a CEO Oh in a well-run
campaign and so I was not the CEO or the
CEO of my campaign I was probably more
like the chairman of the campaign and
and key strategic decisions I insisted
on being a part of and and managed in
the way that that I've just described we
would have probably the eight or ten top
people in the campaign come together and
debate major issues so in a presidential
campaign was I going to play in Iowa
this is in 2012 I played in 2008 and and
found I it would beat Iowa to be
expensive and a good start but not
sufficient was I going to play in Iowa
or was it hopeless and should I just go
directly to New Hampshire and we debated
that at great length and and talked
about a strategy to go forward and and
and selected a strategy which worked
very well within the nomination by the
way it's not easy you know after it's
over it all looks very easy oh you were
obviously getting at the nomination oh
yeah I mean I was behind
Rick Santorum in the last three states I
believe Iowa enamine Iowa Illinois
Wisconsin Michigan also Ohio I think I
was behind five or ten points with only
days to go before the the primary and so
it is tough to do that and I think we
did pretty pretty well I think in the
general election we faced some real
challenges and made some big mistakes
and and but as I look back at the at the
process that we pursued I'm I'm pleased
with the process and pleased with the
people we had a really good team of
people very committed and one of the
things I liked about it
there was not the kind of politics
inside the organization you sometimes
see people you know backstabbing and
trying to claim credit for good things
you know people had strengths and
weaknesses each of our team members had
like myself had real weaknesses but we
worked well by and large and and got a
lot of things right and something's
wrong you mentioned things wrong what
are the big challenges that a Republican
candidate has is that that minority
voters tend not to vote extensively in
Republican primaries or participate in
Republican caucuses they tend to vote in
Democratic primaries and Democratic
caucuses so if you're Jeb Bush right now
or Chris Christie or Marco Rubio or
Scott Walker and you want to get the
nomination you're going to be going to
the people who vote in your primaries
and in your caucuses which will by and
large not be minority voters so for the
next year you're going to watch the
candidates and my side of the aisle
spend all their time with the white
population and typically not a college
is either and then when they get the
nomination when someone finally becomes
the nominee they run to the minority
community and say give me your vote and
they say where have you been alright and
that was a mistake I made which is I was
so anxious to get the nomination I
didn't spend as much time as I should
have
taking my message to minority voters
fighting on minority or in this case
Hispanic TV and radio airwaves getting
my message across even though it
wouldn't help me in the primary
necessarily it certainly was essential
in the general and I think that was
something we missed in our strategy
sessions and in part because we looked
at what had
in the past we said we had to target
independent voters so we went after
independence
I want independent voters one the men in
in Ohio among other states we said hey
if you've got the independent vote in
Ohio you're going to win no they're not
we needed a much better showing among
minority voters and that's a place we've
really messed up and you know so I go
back and say what I've changed the team
I like the team I was proud of the team
we had and the way we work together but
do we make a mistake in strategy sure
that that among others moving to the
idea of running for office people in the
room have come up to me and said they
want to pursue a career in business like
you and then run for office like you I'm
curious if you were to give advice today
to someone like that would you follow
your father's advice which was you know
find a career find a reason not to run
and then run later on when you don't
have so much at stake or would it be
something different in today's age
I'm afraid I'm prisoner my dad's advice
and and I'll tell you why my dad's
advice was because my dad ran for
governor when he was 56 years old he'd
been head of a car company he he felt
that his state was circling the drain
the state of Michigan he saw that that
automobile jobs were leaving his state
going to other states and and other
countries and felt that he had to try
and turn things around
he felt that race relations in the state
were were awful civil rights had not
been advanced as they should that the
schools and the city Detroit were were
just a tragedy and so he got involved
and ran for governor I got involved in
his campaigns
I found politics very exciting and he
said to me is also to my sisters and
brother he said you know I wouldn't get
involved in politics until your kids are
raised and if and only if you're
financially independent and it's like
wow that that's never going to happen I
thought I mean I mean you know working
in consulting is great but it's not
going to make you financially
independent and so I never imagined I
get involved in politics and and what
happened was starting Bain Capital and
then having the stock market take off
and if you're leveraged and the stock
market goes from a thousand to ten
thousand its
good thing alright and so so suddenly I
be conditions became met I
that's the euphemism of the day yeah but
I I personal and I don't think you have
to be financially independent to run for
office I think you have to be able to
meet your mortgage without having to win
the election however and that was what
my dad was concerned about I I think it
really helps if people who who go to
work in the Statehouse or go to work in
Washington actually have experience in
the real economy and in the real world
and can take that experience to
government whether that's in teaching or
working in the Foreign Service or
working in a corporation I think it
really helps to go there with background
and experience that you can share with
others I think that was the concept with
the that the founders had in mind in
forming our republic and that is that
you'd come from a real I mean I look at
John Adams I mean he was a farmer in
Massachusetts went to serve became
president went back home and went back
home became a farmer again and and I
think that's a better model than what we
have right now and so you know my advice
would be yeah work in a real job get
some experience and if the window opens
you see an opportunity to serve locally
statewide nationally then jump in
because good people are needed badly you
another quart you you said in your
documentary was that the other side
often acts like they don't know what
it's like to own a business they don't
know what it's like to have everything
on the line and I see that disconnect a
lot today especially with income
inequality as a burgeoning issue in
particular private equity is something
that you were in tremendously successful
in in the campaign talked about it in a
different way and a lot of our
classmates are going into private equity
or going into these business careers
that are seen as very prestigious here
but maybe elsewhere are seen differently
I'm wondering what you think about that
disconnect and whether there's ways we
can bridge that divide or how you think
about it now well a couple things one
might my concern of
incomes in America is not so much
focused on why some people make so much
as opposed to why are so many people
making so little and we have large
cohorts of people in this country who
have not seen rising incomes and and
have not seen them for a long time and
and so my concern is how do we get
people out of generational poverty how
do we get people out of situational
poverty and how do we get the whole
middle class in America as well as lower
income folks to see rising incomes again
and that that for me is the big is the
big issue I I don't look at people at
Steve Jobs and say you know boy he's a
bad person for making all that money I
look at say thank heavens for Steve Jobs
and Bill Gates and and Scott McNealy and
Marc Andreessen more power to them but
be more and more successful and by the
way if you want to give it all away
during your life that's fine too
great but but so I don't look and say
okay those I don't think those people
are the problem I think the problem is
how come we're not able to lift more how
can we can't get more people to see
rising incomes and and more prosperity
and there are a lot of reasons for that
but but I happen to believe very
fundamentally it profoundly that without
question that the best principles for
helping people get out of poverty and
seeing rising incomes is for is for us
to follow conservative and republican
principles now you might say oh that's
not doesn't make sense you're just the
party of the rich let me tell you
friends the rich will define whether
Democrats are in power liberals are in
power conservatives or Republicans the
rich to fight all over the world the
rich do just fine the people whose lives
are affected by politics and leadership
are the people in the middle and the
people at the bottom end and the reason
I'm a Republican is that I believe the
principles that that my party stands for
or at least that I stand for that those
principles are the best design to help
people see rising incomes again and
better jobs for their kids and the best
principles that get people out of
poverty I mean I don't mean I and we
could have this debate a great at great
length but I think evidence proves it I
think logic proves it that's why I'm a
Republican that's
why I ran for office is that I want to
help people in the middle and in the
bottom see rising incomes and and I
believe that if you're successful in
your enterprise you're going into
business more power to you go out there
be successful build a business work in a
business it's already there make it
better
the better and Enterprise does the more
profit it makes the more you can invest
the more you invest the more you can
grow the more you grow the more people
you can hire the more people that are
being hired the more wages will go up
wages go up because there's demand for
labor that outstrips the supply of labor
that's how they go up and so I want you
to succeed I mean I look at you and and
when you're all highly successful
businesspeople as you hope you will be I
mean I won't look at you and say there's
the enemy I'll say there's my friends I
love you alright I appreciate what
you're doing I want to see you
successful and I want to see as you're
successful I want you to recognize that
your success is contributing to the
success of our country and to those
people who rely on the jobs you'll help
create we only have time for one more
question before we're going to move to
audience QA and it's a simple question
maybe it's just what does the future
hold for you your boxing Evander
Holyfield yeah near future whoo yeah is
a risky I can say is a risky decision
but I you know the term pulling his
punches comes to mind yeah yeah
hopefully yeah yeah but I'm curious you
know what what you want to do next given
all you've accomplished well you know I
I would continue I continue to be
motivated by the same things that got me
into presidential politics in the first
place and so I will work for individuals
who I believe will get America on the
right track to once again create more
jobs than we have supply of labor to see
rising incomes again that means better
schools it means better innovation means
making America the most attractive place
for entrepreneurs and innovators and
businesses of all kinds
it also means an entirely different
foreign policy I happen to think that
the foreign policy of the last six or
seven years has been a disaster and the
globe is feeling it so I want to change
direction
for our country in a way that I think
could be more productive for the safety
of the world and the well-being of the
world for the preservation of Liberty
and for rising prosperity for all
Americans so that how do I do that by
campaigning and raising money for Senate
and congressional seats at the national
level by helping Republican candidates
for president I'd help the Democratic
candidates but they they're not asking
for my advice at this point and there's
only one really hit this stage and and
but I you know I speak regularly with
with people who are running for office
and offer my advice and will continue to
do so and I do a lot of fundraisers and
and speeches and by the way the reason
I'm here during my campaign I wasn't at
college campuses and building the school
in law schools I was at Harvard Law
School last week and I was at Duke and
and I'll be a University of Chicago
coming soon the end of this week I'll be
at it in Jacksonville Florida I speak to
college campuses because I want people
to understand that people who are
conservative are conservative because we
believe the principles of conservatism
are best able to help the middle class
and the poor we know how to end poverty
generational poverty but we're not doing
it because there's not a political will
for it to happen
but so that that's what I'm devoted to
now at the same time I'm back in
business because I want to make sure
that I can provide for myself and my
family without drawing down their
inheritance and and of course every
politician who leaves office says I'm
going to spend more time with the family
I actually am I have twenty three
grandkids and I spending time with the
family and loved it
Thank You Ryan right well we're going to
move to some Q&A now and there will be
mics on the left and the right side so
raise your hand high if you're
interested in asking a question for
those at the top please continue to
tweet your questions and we're going to
start with a question from Twitter so
I'll point in Ninoy over here yeah what
worries you most about the US economy
well I'm concerned that we may be seeing
a bubble and in in tech stocks and and
that we could have the kind of
disruptive event that could cause
that the stock market to collapse and
I'm not I'm not terrified about people
losing money in the stock market I'm
terrified about about going into a
recession again that would put a lot of
people out of work obviously the Fed is
used every tool that has to get this
economy going and if we went in a
recession at this point there not a lot
of tools we're already at zero
effectively zero interest rates so there
not a lot of tools we've where we're
spending massively more than we take in
so we're we're pursuing a highly
stimulated monetary policy and highly
stimulative fiscal policy both so if we
win at a recession at this point that
would be pretty tough I hope that
doesn't happen I think there's some
positive elements on the on the horizon
which one of course is very low cost of
energy which which is stimulative gives
people more money to spend and those
things are encouraging I don't think
we're going to see something of an
immediate nature that causes us to fall
into recession again I sure hope not but
the rest of the world is a little iffy
and it could have an impact on America
longer-term though is might is my
concern longer-term I see America as as
adopting the policies of Europe higher
and higher corporate taxes although
Europe is getting away from that I'll
say the traditional policies of Europe
hired higher corporate taxes higher and
higher levels of regulation higher and
higher personal tax burdens schools that
are being run more for the interest of
the unions and they are for the students
permanent intractable poverty
generational poverty is what I'm
referring to these things give me a
great deal of concern and I'm concerned
about America's innovation lead we the
political class doesn't noticed and
we're in competition the political class
thinks like the American business world
used to think back in the 1960s which
you didn't worry about your competition
you just tried to get better yourself
and then came along strategy which was
the ideas it's not just how good I am on
how good I am relative to everybody else
I can be with and right now we're
competing and the political class
doesn't understand we're competing with
Russia and with China and with the
jihadists and and they've got strategy
they have a strategy
China has a strategy and objectives the
jihadists do
it's America's strategy what's our
global strategy where are we headed what
are we trying to accomplish what are we
doing in Latin America what's our
strategy for North Africa the Middle
East rata ji Hillary Clinton said it
right to diss deciding not to do dumb
things is not a strategy and and so I
mean that that's what concerns me most
about America and about our economy is
that we don't seem to have a strategy
about where we're heading and we're
becoming more and more like Europe on a
number of dimensions education poverty
taxation regulation and foreign policy
and that that gives me concern and
that's why I'm as active as I am still
politically though I'm not running for
office thank you very much we have a
question over here stand up and just
introduce yourself please hi hi Governor
Romney my name is Alex Pearson I'm a
first year also like Ryan I'm from
Massachusetts as well one of the central
themes at the GSB and from the view from
the top program is the power of
authenticity is a tool for effective
leadership we see that in a business but
we see that I think less so in political
leadership and so I wanted to see how
you balanced being the authentic Mitt
Romney versus what you thought the
audience or the kind of Republican
Machine wanted you to be like what do
you wanted to say yeah you know one of
the great challenges in running for
office is that you will be defined by
your opposition and at and and by the
way an attack is very difficult to
respond to without spending all your
time in response I remember the first
time I got attacked and this was when I
was running against Ted Kennedy and and
and my you know I went to my staff and I
said you know we got to answer these
charges these attacks and they said you
know if you're explaining you're losing
the all that's a little catchphrase in
politics if you're explaining you're
losing so you never explain you never
respond to the attacks you just attack
back and the only thing you can do is
attack back just harder and and so these
campaigns are attack attack attack and
by and large it's very difficult in a
campaign to have people get to know who
you really are
I mean in a campaign you spent more time
with me by far and
mean TV time included if you take all
the time you saw during the 2012
campaign of B and compare it with what
we spend in this room we spend more time
now together talking about things we all
care about we choose candidates based on
very little interaction with them and
typically the interaction is watching
30-second ads which are packaged in very
brief and by and large or attacking your
opponent and and then debates and that's
about it
some people have noted you know MIT if
you had just shown that that documentary
that was done on you why the people
would have a different perspective it's
like yeah but who would have watched a
documentary all right
who's going to sit down and watch a one
and a half hour movie on someone running
for office I mean no one's going to do
that because you're going to figure
rightly it was all you know edited for
the campaign by the campaign and and so
I I don't know how we can do a better
job describing and showing who we are
and and my own view was look I was I
served as governor for four years the
positions I had and the postures I took
on issues were the same when I was
governor's when I was running for
president and hopefully people will get
that perspective based on my record but
it's it's a real challenge and and it in
the upcoming election presuming Hillary
Clinton is the nominee and the
Democratic side and she may not be but I
obviously very good for her now
she's pretty well defined in people's
minds pro and con on the Republican side
people aren't as well defined and so
they're going to have a challenge
whoever our nominee is becoming better
known in the mind of the public and the
goal of the opposition will be to define
the Republican at a negative light in a
very negative light and that's just
that's part of the territory you know
getting into a race it's it's you I was
going to say it's not fun the truth is
it is fun running for president is
really fun it's like sport for old guys
all right it's it's a and you come away
passionate about a country more
optimistic about the country you meet
extraordinary people it's a wonderful
experience if you get the chance to run
for president do it for sure but I love
the experience and and you know I just
wait
in a campaign you had more time to be
seen and known by more people and I
think if people did that we'd have a
better shot of electing people we were
happy with after the election yeah
thanks right we have one question over
there yes sir hey my name is Elliott
damage check and I'm a second year MBA
was that been consulting beforehand and
going back afterwards so thank you for
helping to make that exist my question
is around you mentioned that your father
was helped by public assistance programs
a while back and traditionally the view
of the Republican Party is much less
favorable towards those types of
programs so I was wondering how your
view on that has evolved and how its
shaped by your father's experience yeah
thank you actually
there are I got to talk about two groups
of people in poverty one I'll call
situational poverty someone loses a job
or has a life-changing illness of some
kind and the situation means they're now
in poverty those people typically come
out of poverty relatively quickly when I
say relatively quickly they come out of
poverty eventually and and programs to
help them come out of poverty are
extraordinarily helpful and important
and it's can be housing food training
programs childcare and so forth and and
we have a good series of social help
programs for people in that setting I'm
sure they could get better unemployment
insurance as another of those and they
should be fine-tuned and evaluated to
see what makes them more effective but
those work well we're where Republicans
like myself have some angst is is in our
solutions for generational poverty and
that's people who obviously go from
generation to generation in poverty and
don't ever get out back in the 1960s
when I was in high school Lyndon Johnson
declared the war on poverty we today
have record levels of poverty more than
when Johnson was president about 15% of
Americans live in poverty so so why
didn't it work and the answer is the
programs that were put in place in many
respects made it more difficult for
people to get out of poverty I mean the
highest marginal tax rate in America is
not the marginal tax rate for people in
my tax bracket
or yours the highest marginal tax rate
is for the poor if if you're on Medicaid
housing vouchers food stamps and so
forth and you start earning money you're
going to lose all sorts of benefits and
the effective marginal tax rate if you
will benefit tax rate is huge and so we
lock people from it into staying on
government assistance because it would
be crazy for them to get off we make it
almost impossible to get married if for
a poor person if a young person is
pregnant and and she decides to marry
the father of the child she's far less
likely to qualify for Medicaid for
housing vouchers for food stamps and
other forms of assistance the the only
likely way that she'll be able to really
get the support she needs is if the
father provides some of his support that
he has doesn't get married and she gets
medicaid and so forth these other
programs and as a result not
surprisingly huge numbers of people
follow that path there was a study done
by Brookings Institution some years ago
and and I've got the numbers here
directionally right I also go back and
look at the actual numbers but they're
close to these they said what happens in
America if someone graduates from high
school marries before they have their
first child and has ever held a job and
the answer is three percent of those
people will fall in poverty what happens
if someone doesn't do any of those three
things seventy percent of them will be
in poverty it's like aha so if you want
to make sure we eliminate generational
poverty in America one you want to make
sure they're huge incentives to get
people their first job we don't do that
too you want to make sure that schools
are safe and teachers are effective so
we can get people through high school we
don't do that and three you want to make
sure that your government programs
encourage people to get married as
opposed to create disincentives for
marriage which ours do we are doing
exactly the wrong things if we want to
get people out of poverty and yet there
doesn't seem to be any real effort in
Washington to change that so Republicans
are saying by the way when I was
governor I said look I want to spend
more money on childcare and have a
greater work requirement to
get people out of the home and into the
end of the workplace
I'm happy to spend more money on
assistance but I want it to help get
people out of poverty not lock them into
poverty so you support and and
government assistance to and and
alleviate poverty Republicans are all in
favor of but they want to find things
that actually solve the problem as
opposed to cause people to live in
poverty in a human tragedy that goes on
and on and on generation to generation
thanks for the question unfortunately
I'm going to have to take the last
question here why I am wordy aren't I
it's on you off be worried no we we
asked a question of all of you from the
top speakers and it's one that we have
to answer when we apply to the school
and there are obviously a lot of ways
you could answer this so I'm interested
but the question is what matters most to
you and why it's not one thing and all
right so I'm going to give you a longer
answer one another long answer one I
believe in God I know some people don't
but many people who don't nonetheless
believe in something greater than
themselves I believe that that if you
believe in something greater than
yourself that your life will be more
full and unproductive so I believe in
God and by the way in believing in God I
believe therefore we are all his
children and I believe that God loves
all of us and I believe he loves us as
you would love your children some are
doing naughty things some are doing nice
things but you love them all and and and
I believe that I will be measured and
you will be measured based upon what you
have done for your fellow children of
God and and that means your spouse your
children and your community more broadly
so that's a big part of what's important
to me
which are the people around me that I
care for the person I care for most in
life is my wife we met in high school
I loved her passionately she is the most
important person in my life if I could
do anything on any day it would be to be
with her that's what I enjoy most in
life clothes thereafter is to be with my
kids my my boys and there why
and now twenty three grandkids the
greatest joy I have in life is being
with them sitting around in the backyard
or at a beach just being with my
grandkids and family is the greatest
source of happiness and the most
important thing to me coming beyond that
is a circle which includes my church my
congregation the people I know at church
and my sense of service to them service
in the broadest sense giving back in the
sense of caring for people around me is
is follows from that belief in something
bigger than myself I happen to believe
that the currency in life is the people
that you love and they care for you the
friends you have most of what you've
learned here you'll forget the people
you bet here you'll remember the rest of
your life and and we'll form a big part
of your of your wealth
that's your balance sheet when life is
over who loves you and you love and who
are your friends and and and how close
are they to you so what's the most
important thing to me my God my my wife
my kids and and my fellow human beings
and and I participate and engage with
with with people at large through
campaigns through speeches through
serving in charities in all sorts of
ways and and the rewards the rewards
that come back are our rewards in people
in friendship in love and and that's
what makes the most impact in my life
thanks you guys
congratulations to you and best you very
much
you